we've talked about using facial points
as features descriptors indicators
whether there's a facial expression or
not as you can see you can just look at
let's say the angle here and compare
that with the angle here and they are
very useful they're very powerful but
they can't go to everything for instance
if you have a little dimple in the mouth
there's no real movement of the the of
facial point it's just that this mouth
corner is sort of pulling inwards so you
don't get a geometric variation you do
get changes in appearance it's these
kinds of features that we're looking at
when we're looking at appearance
features so they're very good at looking
at first when I open a frown and so
actually when I smile the corner of my
mouth will look very different from a
neutral position so the question then is
how are we going to encode disappearance
and we want to minimize the variation in
our you know features and our scripted
that's caused by things that are
irrelevant to expression such as
lighting or identity and we want to
maximize the variation or features that
are relevant to facial expression and in
our case that's quite open edges so we
want to sort of encode edges in a very
cheap way and a very interesting and
highly successful feature for that is
called the local binary pattern local
binary pattern looks at nine pixels at a
time so it looks at a little block of
three by three pixels and it's
particularly interested at the central
pixel so let's say that the pixel value
of our central pixel is eight and it has
eight pixels around it and it's nine
block let's put in some numbers and that
make some sense a local binary pattern
is now going to turn this set of nine by
nine pixels into a single value and
it'll
do that by first comparing every
neighboring pixel with the central pixel
this is the intensity value or the
luminosity value we're not looking at
color although you could do this three
dimensions but normally people just look
at it in grayscale values so we're going
to compare every neighbor of this center
pixel with the center and if it's
greater than or equal to the center we
will assign a 1 and if it's smaller than
that will assign a zero so 12 is bigger
than 8 so that's a 1 15 is bigger 1 18
is bigger 3 is smaller than 8 as is 2
and 1/8 is equal to 8 so that's a 1
again and 5 is smaller and then we're
going to turn these 8 bits basically
because they can only have a 1 or a 0
value you're going to turn those into
one byte 1 1 1 0 0 0 1 0 as long as
we're consistent we can turn any
ordering of these numbers into one
string of numbers which we then turn
into a decimal number which we will be
using to train our system the nice thing
about these local binary patterns is
that it is illumination invariant if you
change the lighting on the scene all
these pixel values will go up but the
relative difference between the pixels
will remain the same 32 will still be
bigger than 28 so your binary pattern
will remain the same irrespective of
illumination variation in general so
that's a shadow now as long as we're
talking about constant you do get
aberrations you do get difficult
situations at the point where you have a
cast shadow but I'm only at the location
of that cast shadow because we're
usually looking at 3x3 pixels this is
not a big problem because what we're now
going to do is we're going to take a
face and it's our big smiley face think
I'd be better in drawing faces by now
after 10 years of working this area but
I'm not we're going to divide this area
into a number
of blocks the moment I'm choosing 4x4
and this local binary pattern it's
centered on a single pixel and then
compares with its neighbors so basically
we have to do this for every pixel in
this block and each of those will result
in a different decimal number for this
block here you might get values of 2 3 4
2 8 8 13 12 etc and if there's enough
pixels in that block if the block is big
enough we will actually turn these
values into a histogram so basically
looking at the statistics how many times
did 13 come up how many times did 12
come up because there's only 256
different values in this block you
actually get quite robust statistics in
practice we use something what's called
uniform local binary patterns and they
only have 59 different possible values
rather than two and 56 so you get really
quite robust statistics the other thing
that local binary patterns and code is
edges as I said we're interested in edge
detectors in the edges that sort of show
you the outline of the mouth or the
eyelid and as you can see here you've
got three ones then a set of zeros and
one and a zero basically what that means
is that you have a transition here from
a 1 to a 0 you've got a transition here
from 0 to 1 from 1 to 0 again F of 0 1
those transitions are edges so we now
very clearly indicate where you've got a
transition from a light area in the face
to a dark area in the face which is
exactly what an edge is so we've turned
a possibly very high dimensional space
that was based purely on pixel
intensities into a low dimensional space
that only encodes relative intensity
values and in doing so encodes edges so
we now have got an illumination
invariant descriptor of edges when you
think about it facial expression
recognition
is actually action detection you're not
necessarily you're not really interested
in the static smile you're interested in
the fact that I'm you know went from a
neutral face to smiling so you're
looking at differences you're looking at
actions movements and all these
descriptors the appearance descriptors
they only describe the edges in one
frame its static so what you really want
to do is you want to see how these
pixels change over time one way of doing
that is you could actually extend this
block to become a cube and you would get
comparisons between the center of that
cube somewhere down there and all its
neighbors
you would have to ^ 26 different
possible by values and that's just
saying that as it goes back into 3d
that's time communities exactly so if
we're now going to look at not at a
single frame but at a set of frames
let's say three frames so then this is
our Y direction this is our X direction
this is our horizontal and vertical
space it's just a normal image and then
this is time basically saying that this
is the first frame that's the second
frame and that's your third frame you
can now look at the differences not just
within one frame between the central
pixel but also the difference between
this pixel and the pixel at the same
location in the next frame or the pixel
in the next frame but a little bit up
you should get a cube of pixels around
this central pixel 9 in front 9 in back
and 8 surrounding it in the in the
current frame that's a total of 26
different neighbors so you get 2 to the
power of 26 different possible values
and that's a lot
instead you can do a little trick so you
can say I'm still interested in the
changes over time but it might not be
interested in just every possible change
I just want to look at 3 or token all
planes that's it
called the first orthogonal plane of
course being just the XY your normal
image and then you take a slice through
X and T so there's a horizontal slice
and you take a slice through the
vertical and time so that's a vertical
slice there that one is orthogonal to
the X and T and of course it's
orthogonal to the normal XY plane so
that's why it's called three orthogonal
planes in each of the network codes
either edges in space in just your
normal 2d image or an edge in x and time
or an edge in one in time and if you do
this you get 3 times 2 to the power of 8
solutions which is a lot smaller than 2
to the power of 26 and you still
perfectly encode movements actions of
edges over time and if you do this you
will get significant performance
increases
illegal patterns get their own code and
all the illegal patterns get meshed
together into the 59th